hey guys this is andrew for
traincensus.com so
very quickly let me introduce myself for
those who are watching my videos for the
first time
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong
and right now guys i'm doing some
technical analysis on youtube
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you everything that i
learned actually myself and i want to
show you how to use it yourself
so i do really hope that my explanations
are clear enough
and that this is helping you so in
today's video i want to make a huge
update guys on gamestop because we are
entering the third wave
let's get into it
so what is the situation here clearly
it's looking very good guys i did my
last video i'm
always starting on the forest time frame
guys it's the most important time frame
where you know you have the best
reactions in terms of moving averages in
terms of
macd all those indicators that depend on
the time
frame they're gonna give you cleaner
signals
on the forest time frame the daily time
frame is very good
as well the reason why is because you
have both institutional clients
and day traders that are using those
time frame
so here i did my last video guys around
the 170 level
and i told you that we are very
bullish i told you that we are
just completing the first wave of an
impulse that is starting here
we basically had this whole complex
correction guys for those who are
watching my videos
for some time you know that i'm telling
you this for a very long time
right now that i identified this complex
correction that was
a triple three according to iliot wave
theory
that is just here a zigzag another
zigzag and a flat
abc abc and abc so this
whole correction is now complete and
how i know that it's because we're
having here
something very impulsive with finally
the volumes kicking in
so it's not very big yet let's be honest
uh if you look at the daily volumes it's
just the biggest volume we had in the
past two months so this is for me
good enough but it's not the volumes
like it's very low compared to the
volumes we had
when we had this very strong moves up in
uh january and even in march
but it's looking good and so let me just
come back here
i have a lot of things to tell you guys
here so first i was telling you in my
last video that
here this is finally impulsive and
that it looks like for me the beginning
of
something you know of a move up so each
time a move up is going to start
you always going to have an impulse at
the beginning so
once you spot one so here i spotted this
one you know
that this is only the beginning of
something and you know that this
move is probably gonna be the one that
is breaking
some major resistance levels and
here i told you this already like i
think two or three weeks ago
this is the trend line we wanted to
break guys just like we did for amc
look amc is just one step ahead guys amc
broke this trend line so i connect the
high
here and here it broke this trend line
on the 23rd of april that's why i'm so
bullish on amc
and we are one step ahead we already in
the third wave of this
new five-wave development whereas on gme
we are here only breaking this level all
right so we
only completed the first wave here so
what we can expect guys
is just like we had for amc some kind of
a correction here
which is completely normal we're gonna
go back
at those level maybe around 175
in 10 days maybe so this is only one
scenario
but i mean if this happens this is
totally normal
and if we do then here we're gonna have
our third wave
starting the alternative scenario which
is uh more bullish
is that here we keep going higher
so to answer this question so each time
you need to check how many
waves you have in your waves so here
one two three four
five this is working here one
okay two
okay so it can be complete okay i can
find a valid counting where it is
complete
i could also maybe this is a one
i need to zoom in more here i'm doing
this right now with you guys i haven't
done this before
and i'm trying to find so you know idiot
will
never give you only one scenario it will
always be always be a few scenarios
so and you need to find the one that is
fitting the best so here i have one two
three four five you see so this might be
a one
then here we correct one two three
four five okay so this is actually
maybe better so i'm not sure here so in
both cases i think we're going to have a
small correction
maybe to to the 200 level maybe deeper
if actually this first wave is complete
and we need to know where this first
wave is going to go so once again guys
one way for example to know that the
wave is complete
you go back to the basics you go back to
trend lines
and you connect for example here this
trend line
is the one that i'm gonna check to know
if my first wave here is complete so let
me get rid of this
so for now we are still in this wave
development
okay let me go back here
and as long as we stay above the green
line here
we are bullish guys so we might go here
it's possible as well
you know so let's see let's see but
ultimately we're gonna correct
so the higher we go here the lower we're
gonna correct
so if we actually take back you know the
216 level
i told you as well guys about this level
that it's level i wanted to
see taken back and for now we took it
back because it was the maximum level i
had here
you see at the on the 26th
of march we actually traded we had a
high at 216
and all this area as well like was
consolidating around this level
so now the next one for me is the 290
level guys
so this is what is good about like if we
take back
the 216 level
it would mean that then we still need to
correct
i don't imagine the first wave goes
there all right let's be honest
the first wave won't go there i think so
we're going to have some kind of
correction before
the 290 level but let's see how high we
go
on this first wave let me go back on the
hourly time frame
as long as we stay above this trend line
guys
we are still in our first wave so let's
see
where this brings us once again we might
correct
right away it wouldn't be a problem just
like we did with amc so it's possible
that we go here
we get rejected even brutally and then
we're gonna go
do the third wave so here let's see we
need to see more data
we need to know which levels we're going
to reach
but ultimately we're gonna correct
little bits
and then do this third wave that
is gonna involve even more volumes but
for now the fact that we broke
this red resistance here that for me was
the biggest one
to break you know the other ones they
are i would say
some levels that we need to take back
that we're going to come back to correct
but they are not major resistance levels
they are not
some levels that you know can tell us
that actually we don't bearish
if we don't take back for example this
one it would be
really something that makes my whole
analysis different
so i'm very very happy that we
finally take it so once again let's
confirm first
it's confirmed on the on the forward
time frame but is it confirmed on the
daily time frame
not yet all right so i'm here
celebrating a bit early but i'm very
confident
for now we have taken back this level on
the
daily time frame but only one closing
level so we need a second one
to be 100 sure that this level is taken
back
and if we do once again guys expect some
small correction
so depending on how high the first wave
is going the correction might be
you know deeper or not and even like
guys i'm giving you here a lot of
information i know but i think it's
important that you know
you can then use fibs to enter this
trade all right
so you need to wait for the end of wave
one
let's say wave one goes here to 220
okay then to enter with fibs you can buy
the 38.2 retracement level the 50 and
the 1.618 if it goes below the 1.618 it
doesn't look good
i usually you know even buy the 50 the
61.8
and i stop lost everything below the
all right so you can use those fee
retracements to enter your trade
so even a correction to this level to
the 170
would not be for me surprising at all
all right
so we are bullish on the long term uh we
are still bullish on the short term for
now as long as wave one has not
complete by breaking its downward
sloping trend line
that i showed you guys here on the
hourly timeframe we are bullish
so let's see where we are going but
don't be surprised if we have
a small corrections you know that's all
i'm saying and it would be actually a
very nice buying opportunity
so let me quickly show you guys the data
that we're having on gamestop
so as of the 14th of may we having 12
million
so same amount of short interest
in terms of number of shares what is the
option data telling us
so gamestop is was at 170 so we had
five percent of synthetic short interest
at 215
we are having eight percent guys and i
checked
this you know 800 strike that is just
insane it's growing guys we have
now three million shares here of
position
so you can see that the synthetic shot
is still driven
more by the 200 strike than the 800 but
things will change if we go higher
say we go to 350 you can see that
the 800 strike synthetic short position
is growing much faster than the 200
one and this is what is going to create
some
gamma squeeze actually on the upside is
this crazy amount guys you know
once again i've said this many times but
it's very important to remind us guys
we usually don't have this kind of shape
on the option market usually we have a
concentration around the money
and on gamestop and amc we're having
this like
very upside calls that are actually
heavily
heavily bought by written investors and
this
is what can create a gamma squeeze on
the upside yeah
one more thing so now we're having eight
percent of synthetic throat so if i add
it to the
regular shot interest which is 20 we
having 28 percent of total short
interest guys
so it's the highest level we've seen
since
the first squeeze so you can see that
hedge funds
they don't want to let this trade go
they're still selling
for now to me it's not enough once again
to create the squeeze my scenario would
be we first go to 800
then they're gonna short massively guys
at this level
and then it might squeeze so to insane
levels of course for now
we are just developing higher in a kind
of normal way
but the one week dtc as the volume has
not increased a lot
is very high actually is the highest
level we've seen
uh same since february so you can see
that
the pressure is actually uh growing here
those numbers are becoming hot
so let's see what is gonna happen but
once again guys
uh for me we are only in the first wave
of our third wave
so i expect some strong strong moves up
to come
soon so that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
show see you guys